so I gotta ask yeah talk to him the
first time when I saw him and T Grizzly
were working together the first thing
that came in my mind was like [__] I've
DJ'd at a nightclub
that Sada was at and I was asked not to
play t Grizzly yep and I was like whoa
[__] because I knew you guys had like
you know you're falling out but whatever
it was I didn't know how you would feel
about them working together and it was
so amazing to see you guys together yeah
because I feel like man
what was that like for you to put that
behind you bro I feel good man
uh I feel real good just like
[__] was long overdue
um whatever I wanted to Harbor my
[__] anger about was some [__]
I felt like I had the right to be mad
about for a long time but in the same
token it was hindering the progress of
[__] around me and
is she a Bros tagging some money but
more so than anything I'd be liking to
feel good you know what I'm saying and
looking at so much [__] and staring at
[__] that [__] don't be feeling good you
know what I'm saying like I want to get
back to feeling good like I caught up
coach been in the house for like two
years you know what I'm saying
before [__] was bad before she was
starting to get good like and the guy
still was just in the house you know
what I'm saying like I'm hanging my hat
on blaming it on missing my daddy but
like [__] gotta get up and do something
you feel me so
I missed him and I feel like he missed
me too and little brother put it
together and [__] whatever the [__] was
an issue that [__] don't exist no more
you know what I'm saying we going
forward I love it it's a it's a big deal
[Applause]
that's a big deal man we need to do that
more you know yeah at the end of the day
ain't nobody gonna kill each other do no
[__] like that we might as well just
like yeah and it's the money keep it
moving and you know it's about the
energy and the vibrations you know and
it's good for the city to have two of
the OG's to the guys
I feel like you and him really kicked
the door down for guys like skill uh for
guys like I mean you know although this
whole new Detroit
and so just I just think like there's
just to have the harm Harmony between
you guys is big for that for the city
yeah because we've seen Star Wars yeah
yeah they Mount Rushmore for not Mount
Everest I mean [__] like I swear to God
like I like I I appreciate any knowledge
that they give me but I'll really be
giving the [__] about I know how he feel
about me you feel me and then a few of
my [__] close to me feeling I
really be standing on that because
you get to looking for
how can I say it uh validations and
areas where a [__] think you don't care
but like to be honest [__] damn they
care about all this [__] you feel me
right you get to looking for them knives
you bring you right you really ain't
gonna get them now all the time because
[__] go with fads and what's
going on in the knowledge today looking
at a lot of facts you know what I'm
saying like
and to keep myself being caught up in it
you feel me like I I gotta try to not
pay attention to it and just
hold on to knowing that I got real love
coming from this [__] I got real love
coming from this [__] yeah then the
[__] I love for real so like
yeah if we if I did do some [__] for the
city you feel me I just was trying to
stay true to [__] knowing that
I'm from Detroit but as far as me
looking for a [__] to do that
if he say I'm up there then all right
I'm happy I'm doing my due diligence and
his ass yo crazy you didn't make the
freshman cover by the way it was one of
the wildest snubs of the Year
man I don't feel like it's a snub though
I thought it was I don't why not I don't
either I don't know I mean last year
there was two guys from Detroit right
this year I was like yo like I mean
Detroit to me just moving even faster
bigger I don't feel like I'll do it you
got one of the best albums of the Year
enough I ain't did enough
I don't know man I don't know bro
yeah maybe next year like but as far as
as far as like you saying that that
ain't like
you shut up bro cause I'd be saying I
don't feel like I did enough though like
like as far as musically right like yeah
for my city I'm big in my city and stuff
like but like on the worldwide level
yeah I got a record now you know it's
[__] on that that made that [__]
that's that's not worldwide neither and
like bro but you not all right so hit me
up if you hear me you know I know it's
cool I just want to talk to him bro
[__] you not local you did a whole
[__] lot
uh a [__] alive they say they don't see
your [__] more so than bro it's the
[__] on that [__] bro I never heard
they names before and I'm not just
saying that because I want to tell you
to see your face you feel me bro you did
a lot brother but you know what I'm
saying and and and
more so than just saying you did a lot
bro I don't know what their standards is
or what they hold the bar from as far as
like what you doing but [__] you did
enough if I had to say something you
know what I'm saying to make the [__]
bro I understand you've done more than
I'd be feeling like it's different
Marcus and music maybe maybe they know
some stuff that we don't know you feel
me as long as I sell records and I
Elevate and I get better with my craft
I'm satisfied but I don't feel like like
I just wowed the whole world to where I
just had to be on the fresh release no
y'all saying that and y'all got y'all
got like your opinions matter to me no
bro okay so I I hear you saying that but
[__]
who the [__] on on that we're wearing
right there
all 12 of them didn't wow the [__]
world bro like [__] it's it's it's
granted it's some [__] on there [__]
yes I've heard they music for sure could
I not but like [__] I've heard your
[__] non-biasedly I've heard your
[__] [__] more so than I've ever
heard a song from like three people on
them yeah a few people and there's no
knock today but [__] you feel me you
know how I be feeling about that
situation so I hope it's like [__] I
I know you but now wisely I still would
know you and still not have heard them
[__] like say I wouldn't meet you and
I'm just on Tick Tock or Instagram bro
[__] yo songs is everywhere yeah yeah
gorgeous shit's going up gorgeous right
now but gorgeous weren't really going
nothing but like no right now right now
let's go I mean that's what I'm saying
you still was juicing though yeah you
was juicing but it's like I'm I'm
limited well back then I was limited to
a certain Market of people like and
gorgeous and they also probably put that
list together like
I heard that they a few people I bought
their way on this year and they haven't
done that before but I mean it's so
funny
it's a magnet yeah it was a different
type of group of people on there like it
was singers as dancers right some
rappers yeah like I liked um like they
like their rare they had uh one thing
what's the singer [__] names
Friday Friday's though I liked Friday on
there
um
uh what's going on there a little
brother she deserved to be on there glow
uh rifle man
I've seen people that's like more like
um EDM music that's what it's called
yeah
you feel me so I know like I wouldn't
understand how big they are the music is
in their Lane you know I'm not saying I
never I don't listen to that music so I
don't but we wouldn't know but it looked
like they do EDM you get what I'm saying
like Okay it looked like they do EDM so
what the [__] would we know he said they
look like
just like let's say this baby try and
stream more than everybody in Detroit
okay so you don't play him in the clubs
right feel me no but he's one of our top
rappers right but you would never hear
baby child in the club but he got some
of the biggest songs it'd be like
somebody just going to the club and only
determining what's hot from from just
the one please no it's just no it's he's
from Detroit but like what his crowd is
it's a crowded [__] that's not
in the industry right right right he
don't make ghetto ratchets
one of the best leaders first time I
played trying in the hood for for cousin
them on Van Dyke [__] same area y'all
was in [__] [__] like what the [__]
is this food what you got on the damn TV
and I'm like bro this [__] ass [__]
sweet I'm trying to hear y'all [__]
gonna get it